-Today is Friday,
and that's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and I, of course,
send out thank-you notes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Feels good to hear applause.
We haven't heard that in a year.
That's amazing.
-Wow!
-Thank you, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was running
a bit behind today.
-Really?
-Yeah.
So I was getting --
-Why's that?
-Well, remember all those
tattoos I got removed?
-Yeah.
-I'm reapplying them.
-Are you serious?
-Yeah, I second-guessed it.
-Really?
-Yeah.
So I spent all day doing that.
And I forgot to write out
my thank-you notes.
So I was just wondering,
can I write it out right now?
Do you guys mind?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate that.
James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
♪♪
-Okay.
-Wow.
-He's just Zooming in.
That's not even James.
-Wow.
-I think his picture froze.
-He looks great.
[ Laughter ]
-You know it feels good
to be here for this.
-What's that?
[ Music stops ]
[ Laughter ]
-I haven't been here all year.
This is the first time
in a year I've seen you --
-Yeah, you were waiting,
and I was about to do it.
-You guys are working.
I had to be at home,
hanging out.
-Yep, I understood.
-Goofing off.
-But then here it is.
-But you guys held
the fort down, yeah.
Glad it's here.
-Wow.
-Just, thank you.
I love you.
I'm glad I'm here.
That's all.
-All right, man.
You know what?
[ Applause ]
It's all about timing, you know?
-Yeah, it is.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause my heart, just --
You know what I mean?
It's, like --
It feels good to see you.
It feels good to see The Roots.
Feels good to see an audience.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Go ahead.
I can't wait to hear these.
-Feels good to see you.
-Yeah, I can't wait
to hear these.
-You can't wait, yeah.
It's about to happen.
-Well, I love them. They're my
favorite part of the show.
-Yeah. Well, here it is,
right here for you.
♪♪
-I also love --
[ Laughter ]
-Many things --
There's many things
that we could do.
-I love many things.
But go ahead, you go ahead.
-I just want to
talk to the control room,
see if we can
turn your microphone off.
[ Laughter ]
They said yes.
-[ Imitating mic cutting out ]
I --o --ove it.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
-My mic wasn't...
-I was doing a bit.
I was doing a bit.
I was doing a bit,
pretending my mic was cut.
'Cause, you know what
the most important thing --
This is the only -- This is
the last thing I'm gonna do.
This is the lesson I learned
through all of this
whole horrible,
all of the stuff,
all the horrible things
were happening,
the people --
the best to me.
That's all.
-Your mic cut out.
That was a beautiful thing
you just said.
-Yeah, go ahead.
I'm good.
-Oh, that was --
I wish we had the microphone on.
-Oh, what's that?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
Biden's press conference,
for feeling like going
to a Yanni concert
after four years
of listening to Slipknot.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh.
-I like Yanni.
-Come on.
♪♪
-Thank you, "Godzilla vs. Kong,"
for giving vaccinated couples
the ultimate reason to go out,
watching two hours of
a different couple fighting.
[ Applause ]
"It's not us!"
-"Not us, baby."
-"It's not us.
That's all that matters."
♪♪
Thank you, giant ship
blocking the Suez Canal,
for causing flashbacks
for anyone that's had
to move a couch into
a New York City apartment.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
You know what I'm talking about.
-My fingers.
-"What if we move it this way?"
-"Flip it like an L!
Flip it like an L!"
♪♪
-Thank you,
Pepsi's new Peeps-flavored soda,
for turning "Is Pepsi okay?"
into, "No, seriously,
is Pepsi, like, okay?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Mmm.
Yellow can.
-Did you get that?
-I got it.
-What'd you think?
Okay.
-Eh...
[ Laughter ]
-Never mind.
-Eh...
[ Laughter ]
-They can't all be winners.
You know what I mean?
-You talking about the jokes
or the soda?
-Everything.
[ Laughter ]
If everybody's a winner --
Somebody's gotta
watch the parade.
That's all I'm saying.
You know what I mean?
Every joke can't be a winner.
Every soda can't be a winner.
Go ahead.
[ Laughter ]
-That joke was pretty good.
-Yeah, I loved it.
-Is it your favorite?
-I'm just saying,
as a general note,
all things can't win.
Somebody's got to be number two.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
-Why would you point to me
when you said "number two"?
-No reason.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't want
to point any fingers, but, uh...
[ Laughter ]
-You have three pointing
back at you.
-Every finger's pointing at me.
-You have 10 fingers?
-Wow.
-Two thumbs.
♪♪
-Thank you, Joe Biden supporting
universal pre-k,
although I'm pretty sure
it's just so that
you'll have somewhere
to leave Pete Buttiegieg
between 9:00 and 3:00.
[ Applause ]
He's young.
-He's just a young man.
-He's a young man.
-Don't judge.
-Come on.
♪♪
Thank you, spring,
for introducing us all
to the fun new game,
allergies or COVID?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"That's it -- I got it!"
-"I got COVID.
What do I do?"
-"Scratchy throat, yes."
-Don't go to WebMD!
Oh, my gosh, I'm gonna die.
♪♪
Thank you, spring cleaning.
I can't wait to clean my house
and wipe down every surface
after spending a full year
cleaning my house
and wiping down every surface.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Oh, dude, you can do
your best impression.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Imitating spray bottle ]
-A Windex bottle.
-Ready? Do it.
-Ready?
-[ Imitating spray bottle ]
[ Imitating window squeaking ]
[ Imitating spray bottle ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitating birds chirping ]
[ Imitating gunshot ]
[ Imitating bird falling ]
Pbht!
[ Laughter ]
-Man...
-It's been a while.
-Yeah, well...
-Steve Higgins, everybody.
-It's been a while!
Come on!
We're back!
-For your consideration,
Emmy voters.
[ Laughter ]
Right?
-Any voters.
♪♪
Thank you, firing up the grill
the first time this season,
for reminding me that I meant to
clean the grill last September.
[ Applause ]
"Eh, it'll burn off."
"That makes it taste better."
-"You need the grill,
you need the soot,
you need the grease."
-"That makes the burger
taste better."
-"Without it,
it's just propane."
-"That's like eating --
I'd rather eat nothing."
[ Laughter ]
"I'd rather starve myself."
-"I'd rather starve myself
than eat off a --
A guy who eats off
a clean grill --"
-"Is a real idiot."
-"Yeah.
Is no good in my book.
Might as well kick him
in the cojones."
[ Laughter ]
-"That's what I would do.
If someone tried to cook me
a clean burger
on a clean grill..."
-"Right."
-"I'd kick that person
in the cojones."
-"It's the only logical thing
to do!"
-"Exactly."
-"You got logic on your side.
You got mathematics,
you got logic,
you got everything on your side
telling you
you're in the right."
-"I'm so happy
you're my neighbor."
-"Me too!
I'm so glad we live in this --
in this shipping container
in the back of the Walmart.
I love it."
-I think it's --
[ Laughter ]
-It's been a year!
Come on, man.
Little rusty.
-Little rusty.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, matzah, or as I call
you, swole saltines.
There you have it, everybody!
Those are my thank-you notes!